[Music]
several years ago i was very fortunate
to be able to purchase a cabin like a
couple cabins on a lake
i have a garden which i spent a lot of
time in you have a real green thumb
thank you i i enjoy it i mean whether or
not i'm good at it i just enjoy doing it
i was getting really frustrated because
i i put in a fence to keep the wood to
keep the wood chucks out and uh i
noticed that the plants were still being
eaten different types of plants so the
woodchucks had stayed out the next
morning sure enough the plants were
something was still eating them
and i sat out there one day
looking out of the garden and i saw a
little the culprit a little chipmunk
little they're all over the yard these
chipmunks and they were so i chased it
out i thought it had gotten stuck and
they were maybe gone underneath the
fence and i i ran over the garden and it
squeezed its way out of one of the
little tiny i mean these holes were like
god it must have been like a centimeter
in diameter i don't know how it got
through there yeah i would think that
chipmunk would have more respect for you
than that
right yeah you're alvin yeah thanks as
alvin would say i don't get no respect
such a good alvin impression thanks well
you know you are out
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your former chipmunk host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
and with me is always his christian
uh you like chipmunks i would be um in
our family structure i would have been
theodore yeah but i think i'm a bit more
of a science simon yeah you are now when
we were growing up you're alvin you are
alvin i always identified more with
alvin when we were growing up you you
are very alvin yeah kind of that could
be a good um
new lightning round question oh favorite
chipmunk what chipmunk you identify with
because they're pretty different they
are they are i don't know if people are
familiar enough
with the different personalities though
i don't know who would identify with
theodore really i i feel like he'd be
the least popular uh
like cute and quiet
yeah but and he's kind of like a little
is he dim he's a little like not damn
innocent he's a real innocent he's like
the betty white yes he's like the rose i
was just thinking that yeah you don't
both have to think that rose and
theodore have very similar
characteristics uh yeah i damien would
definitely would have been simon
when he was growing up yeah he
was um
it's almost like they wrote her was
written for him yeah
um and you know they had offered not to
i don't know what this is i was going to
qualify it with like sorry to brag but
they offered me simon this is how like
arrogant it's not a it's a
they believe it or not they offered me a
smaller part and i insisted on the lead
the sign i don't even know if i'd say
simon was a smaller part i think they
they were calvin and the chipmunks i
know it's called that but in the in the
movie i think they were all pretty much
the same size doesn't matter still alvin
the chipmunks he's alvin is the
why are we talking about alvin and the
chipmunks because our guest today is
uh an actor who appeared in three of the
alvin the chipmunks movie he's going to
love this he's going to love that this
is mostly what he's known for no that's
not true our guest today is the
brilliant comedian one of my favorites
if not my favorite comedian uh david
cross uh
god was i excited when he agreed to do
it i've always wanted i've known david
for a while not through really
alvin movies but um
i don't know how i mean we've both done
chipmunk nation not chipmunk nation no
in fact you know i i was never i never
worked with him directly on those things
we would record separately uh
and he
but i knew him through friends in new
york and we would do uh these plays
called the 24-hour plays for um
american airlines theater every couple
of years so uh and i think we had done a
play one of those together anyway i've
spent limited amount of time with him
but always so enjoyed being around him
he's so i mean as you imagine he's just
so naturally funny and and
uh perceptive and
brilliant i think so smart just was such
a i mean like intimidatingly smart he's
most known
for um i would say arrested development
mm-hmm
yeah mr show and mr show with bob and
david with with uh his his comedy
partner uh bob odenko hopefully future
guest the show he'd be great i i didn't
tell david this um because i didn't want
to you know i was very so i didn't want
to gush too much and i'd you be the
judge whether or not but um
when i was uh a young man when i was in
college
the thing i cared about more than
anything was the sketch comedy group
that i was in called laughingstock and i
just it was the source of so much joy so
much fun i just
loved it and um
and our heroes like my friends and i we
all really worshiped mr show that to me
was like the because snl was fun we of
course it was an institution we loved
that that was a big inspiration but
there's something about mr show that was
like so subversive and uh it was it was
just like another level it was punk it
was punk yeah truly he's just uh
incredibly intuitive and
i i really think brilliant so
um i was excited to talk to him and i
hope you
because he has a new movie
that we should mention here the dark
divide it is uh
well we talk about it and uh we will
talk about it afterwards
it's about a naturalist who goes into
the wild in search of um
a certain type of butterfly but really
in search of himself that sounds
hilarious no it's it's actually not it's
not it's not a comedy it's um it's
closer to like a jack london
uh novel or into the wild or something
like that it's it's about self-discovery
and he looks incredible in it he looks
so good i think he's a phenomenal actor
he doesn't get credit for all the time
because of how funny he is but um my
challenge was to not as you say chris
farley him
which is christian always like advises
me against the chris farley showing us
now yeah like remember when you said
that thing yeah i found funny 15 years
ago
it's like yeah i i remember it yeah i
wrote it and said it i i had to really
hold myself back because there's so much
i can't wait okay hard to hear whether
you succeeded or not okay here we go you
could all be the judge of that as
christian will be um
when you hear my
chat with the uh
just beyond funny and bright david cross
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
i see you shaved your beard a little bit
i was
excited to talk to you you had a very
intense beard earlier
uh yeah that was uh that was the first
thing i did when i wrapped i was like
this thing i could bring it down that
was crazy but that was you know meant to
be
you know that was all real obviously no
prosthetics but that was all lost in the
woods for
you know a couple months do you so you
grew it for the character because uh you
you're playing a
naturalist dr pyle and um i got that
just the story of the shooting it um is
so fascinating but it's
you're out in this wilderness i had no
idea there was such an expanse of
wilderness oh nor did i i didn't know i
i had no idea that's untouched you know
that they wow um
uh and who knows how long that'll last
uh like
you know that was one of the things we
talked about when we were
starting to make the movie was uh you
know who knows how long we're
going to have this you know to to
play around in before it's uh well you i
don't know if you saw trump just opened
up
the entire uh
uh i can't remember the name of the the
where you're at the pin show
uh national forest did he touch any of
that is he touching no no but uh uh i
want to say the it's not tongas but
something close to that uh in alaska
this is yesterday i read this that
they're just opening up the whole
place for uh oil drilling oh god are
they doing the entire like whatever it
is 16 000 acres oh my god yeah i mean
since since watching the material on the
movie i've seen some scenes in the
trailer you look about you just i i
people are always uh
you know i'm sure you're sick of hearing
uh
there's some versions of this but
you look so different in the movie i
mean your performance is not i think
what people might expect it's something
that didn't surprise me though um
because
you were you've always to me been such a
natural grounded performer and and uh
you're just you know it's a different
part maybe but
was that something that you
consciously sought out were you looking
to do something
like this
um i mean yes and no i wasn't i don't i
didn't really seek them out they sought
me out but uh uh speaking to that i
because i don't i i haven't had
you know many opportunities uh if any to
do this kind of thing which is very
um
dramatic you know it's a guy who
goes into the woods and he's um wait you
know and way way way over his head and
uh
um and struggling with the loss of his
what i'm not telling you right i know
you know
i don't know if you remember um your
wife in the movie i know i never read it
oh you could yeah that's my process is i
just go where what just don't don't give
me any don't give me i don't want to
know oh oh so you're going to love it
once you see it you're going to be
really surprised you're going to get to
follow along with the audience yeah
well i hope you make it
i know does he die at the end yeah i
don't want to tell you i don't want to
spoil him okay all right um
you but but you're you're so you're
grappling with this really intense
the material is is you know it's heavy
as
marty mcfly would say and um
you you uh i that's again it doesn't
surprise me but are people when you're
talking about this kind of work are
people did they preface questions that
way are they like well i would not
expect this from you david cross yeah
and you know you see the um
there are
some reviews that are like uh
that are basically it's not simply a
review but it's also warning people like
he's not
it's not that funny
[Laughter]
don't
is there less pressure for you then when
you're promoting something like this to
be so i just i saw some clips um they're
always so funny on talk shows but but i
it occurred to me that there must be
pressure
when you're promoting a comedy
album
you know that's specific to
that's comedic uh there must be added
pressure to be funny and is or is there
not or do you not never really feel that
uh you know what it when you're doing
those kind of quick uh
you know like late night shows then then
there's that pressure to be funny but
when you're doing uh something that's
like you know you go
you know those kind of like serious
tours serious radio tours
promotion that's like this that's a
little bit longer
um
i definitely
you know you
i understand i go into an understanding
i'm supposed to be funny and i've
certainly seen enough
uh comments after i've done somebody's
thing where it's like that guy wasn't
funny he got all serious i don't want to
hear about trump or whatever
but i i mean at this point i don't care
yeah hopefully there's enough
funny if it's not funny it'll it will at
least be interesting
do you have hope yeah yeah
well we'll see
um have you
so so in terms of i mean i i obviously
this was something that came to you but
um just career-wise uh shaping your
career um
was it was it important to you to do
something a little bit more
dramatic a little bit less obviously i
mean again it was the the
they came to me it was a combination of
the opportunity and the material i think
if
if the material wasn't as strong and um
uh intriguing to me then i i
possibly wouldn't have done it um but it
was such a
uh and also i met with the
writer director tom putnam and he
subsequently went on to write numerous
books and and that's sort of the thrust
of his career when when this
the time that this movie takes place
which is 1995 which is when he went for
the for this thing
um
he wasn't a writer yet and now he is a
big you know full writer but uh um he's
the old writer what is that
full-blown he has full-blown writing
disease um he uh it it's i think the
book is the book called in search of
bigfoot it's a nat he's a naturalist dr
pyle but is he actually looking for
bigfoot or do they just use that as like
a metaphor for the no he and again the
movie is a bit of a um it's an
amalgamation of a bunch of different
things that that occurred to him over
the years and it's just put into this
one story um
taken from a bunch of his books but
in
the dark divide the the book that this
is based on all that stuff does happen
to him he stumbles upon
what could be
construed as evidence of bigfoot um or
at least the appearance of evidence and
it's up to you to decide whether that's
uh the movie doesn't say he exists or he
doesn't yes um people would be
disappointed isn't about yeah it's not
about bigfoot it's a thing that is
thread through that kind of happens
about a third of the way into the movie
where he stumbles upon this stuff and
then it completely
you know he's forced to rethink a lot of
his things because he is a scientist
yeah he's uh
butterflies and moths yeah lepidopterist
yeah
that was his thing before he
you know the reason he went on this
journey is because his wife
before she dies fills out an application
for a grant to guggenheim for him to
allow him to do this and it's something
that and she was the extrovert and the
very social
person in the relationship and he was
just more of a um
kind of not necessarily anti-social but
just
uh
she was the active person the proactive
person in the relationship and he had
for years you know been saying like oh
yeah i'm going to do this i want to do
it but he just never got around to it
because he'd find excuses and
it was always like well um it's it's
going to be rainy this season so i'll
probably wait until and it was always
just
putting it off and putting it off
because he was scared yeah ready and he
wasn't and then when she
she knows she's dying everybody you know
it's it's clear it's one of the last
things she does before she dies and
unbeknownst to him so after she's dead
uh he gets a letter saying you've gotten
this grant and he's thrilled and then he
sees what it's for it's for a uh to walk
all 124 miles of that
of what's known as the dark to buy this
give her pinshot trail which is a crazy
it's crazy it's the
you know just making the movie where we
had
you shot there then obviously oh yeah
yeah and um
i think we shot for four and a half
weeks and uh 22 days i think i read god
yeah it was uh we shot a week in
[Music]
um or at least three or four days in
portland
and then we moved to kind of the outer
areas of mount hood but then when we go
in there when we go into like mount
adams and mount hood and we get into the
trail like we were in the trail and
there's no
you know you you bring in skeleton crew
yeah i bet
how do they there's no roads you go to a
road and then you have to hike in for a
mile with all this equipment holy [ __ ]
there's no phone service there's no how
do they do that they just have
generators they bring generators yeah
you know and you you start you know
you're charging stuff up and you're
walking off the trail and then and that
all the stuff in the in and around the
lava tubes was crazy intense yeah i
didn't know they existed i read about
these lava what describe that or it's
like cold lava
i mean obviously
so what does that look like what is that
like being there it's um
well it's all you know it's it's uh uh i
don't know exactly but
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
years old and there's all the the tubes
that are probably i mean i'm gonna guess
roughly
100 feet if not
bigger of these everything's jagged and
all the earth is around you have to
descend into these things i mean it's a
you have to strap in you have to get a
safety harness and go down these like
it honestly looks like um
the entrance to
a bond villain's laboratory like a lair
yeah
like it's it's you can't really tell
from the outside and then there's like a
door that's covered with grass and you
move that aside oh [ __ ] and there's like
a seven foot steel
vault thing and you descend those like
diamond
metal uh uh these air wells and you have
to um you know there's like clanking you
have to wear special equipment oh my god
all to just get to the shooting area i
mean yeah
and it's really dangerous and uh the air
is different down there it's like
thicker all that stuff that you see in
the film kind of looks underwater-ish
that's all those are particles that's it
that's all real oh my god it was i'm
gonna guess it was about 40
42 43 degrees wet it's all damp and you
shot in the summer time this is in the
summer right may yeah but you're so far
down there's oh my god i mean there's no
sunlight there's no there's no seasons
there's no seasons there's no um there's
no air there's no ventilation
do you have breathing apparatus like do
you have um oxygen tanks and stuff are
you um we didn't but i will say that uh
several people had to go to
a get checked at a hospital
um god and we had and there was a uh
when we were in that pit kind of that
i'm going to call it a pit whatever that
where i get lost in the what do you call
it the compass doesn't work anymore that
it's too bad david i have to confess
they only sent me they sent me three
scenes in the trailer and then all the
so i i i've yes
there's like a pit where anyway getting
down there somebody else got injured had
to go that we had a number of injuries
uh
shooting the
movie and did you ever think this is
probably ignorant to say but did you
ever think
can we shoot this a little closer to
portland you know some somewhere a
little bit less
severe uh i'll tell you exactly where
that happens there's a part where i fall
into a river
there's uh i'm trying to cross this
branch i'm trying to make my way across
the stream
and uh i fall into the river and
there's no you cannot tell and i brought
this up i i mean this this was actually
a point a big point of contention for me
you can't tell when you watch it that
that water is
whatever it is 35 degrees
right and all that water was literally
was ice uh 25 minutes ago it's from the
mountain oh my god it's uh it's melting
and it goes down that's what the river
and the river holy [ __ ] and
you know it was it was a
hypothermia was a real danger an issue
and i oh yeah couldn't shoot it the way
it would normally have shot it and there
was uh um
uh the
safety health safety team that was there
was like pull them out pull them out now
like i'd get in
for and i i've never experienced in my
life
the fog
of when hypothermia starts setting up
like a uh because i had to go under
water oh and the director was going you
got to go under what i was like and when
you see the movie and you'll hear me
going you'll see it you'll hear me go no
can't that's all real that's me trying
to leave and get out yeah i was gonna oh
my god i was gonna ask you it must make
it not forget easier you just don't act
you're not acting in a lot of times no
acting yeah uh i mean it's honestly
preservation self-preservation it's like
get me the [ __ ] out of here stop
shooting the safety guys were like pull
them out you know get grabbing me oh my
god they had that
aluminum looking blanket that they have
one of those thermal ready to go yeah
they had they had a countdown you know
they could i was only allowed in for x
amount of time and i didn't go
underwater the thing is you cannot tell
right right when you watch it right how
cold the water is i could have shot that
in a [ __ ] swimming pool heated
and you're a good actor it's like let me
act
it's like uh the way i describe it is
like putting um you know when you go to
the dentist you get x-rays they put that
kind of heavy leg
yeah
it's like that over your brain it's just
oh my god i couldn't there were words i
couldn't think of and uh i couldn't
communicate it goes away pretty quickly
i mean i'd say within a couple minutes
yeah funny getting back to
i was just kind of yeah
but i couldn't i kept saying um i
couldn't think of the word trailer i was
trying to describe
uh go back you know the
and i couldn't i didn't have the words
oh god that's terrifying
i kept referring to
portland as puerto rico like trying to
say we could
do it in puerto rico and like people are
not understood
eventually that only lasts a couple
minutes
well that must be terrifying for you
especially because you seem like
somebody who really values
their mind you're so good with words and
i really admired that about you the way
you you you're so descriptive when you
tell a story that must be
particularly scary for you well it gives
you a a very brief but stark idea of
what dementia might be about somebody
like you don't you can't think of the
words and i know i have the picture in
my head and i'm trying to say it and i
can tell by the reaction that it's not
making any sense yeah but that again
that only lasted a few minutes and then
i was you know well also david how
delicate we are how how we're all
slaves to this
mechanism in our heads that uh at the
time you probably wanted it to be puerto
rico your body probably wanted it to be
puerto rico
instead of portland god so when you see
the movie now
you think or or when you eventually see
the movie
do you think you'll think oh god we
this could have been this will i be able
to tell that it's you're in the elements
or could it be anywhere
no i mean i knew that when we were
shooting it and then you know i was a
part of the editing process and you know
there's adr and all that stuff so i've
seen it
i've seen the movie now you know yeah
dozens of times probably won't see it
again until my kids grown up or
something i show it to her but i i knew
that then and and of course you can look
at it and go i mean i guess if you
go hiking a lot and you're familiar with
that yeah you would you would
kind of fill in the blanks going boy i
bet that water's really cold but outside
of that you can't you can't right
but the but the rest of it it must have
been important to you to the filmmaker
to tom to
to the author to shoot it there i mean
for it that strikes me as such an
important part of the character almost
in the movie well but also it's stunning
it's beautiful yeah
uh i mean there's a bunch of drone shots
and you get they did an amazing job of
just saying like this is where we are
and it and i've i've never
spent any time in the woods in the
pacific northwest which is you know i've
spent plenty of time
are you a camper do you like to go camp
are you an outdoorsy at all person i
mean i'm outdoorsy but i'm not like uh
i'm not a two weeks i'm not a roughing
it guy
uh you know i'll i'll spend a night in a
in a tent that's got some amenities yeah
a yurt yeah
um
wow so that alone
not at all wow but you knew
what the shoot was going to be like what
it was going to entail um
yeah yeah but it's all it was all kind
of vague it was i sort of i i mean it
wasn't real in the in that sense until
you get out there and then you're like
oh we do we this is as far as we can
take vehicles and we've got another you
know three quarters of a mile to get in
here and
and i did do some prep work where i went
out with the survivalist and then and he
taught me some stuff and i went into
some of the trails that we started
shooting that were
more accessible and
and you see how stunning yeah it is
there but uh once you really get into
the interior it's it's
magical and ethereal
it's just a woods that i haven't really
ever encountered i i'm mostly east coast
yeah in georgia and and and maybe new
york and massachusetts yeah i'd love to
explore
out there it's different man it's it's
green it's more you feel
you're smaller there life could be a
dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello
[Music]
hello don't know how you felt about
bigfoot before uh this experience but i
would imagine that it makes the reality
of this all right
i would imagine
it makes the reality of their the
possibility of that kind of creature uh
a lot more um believable you know a lot
more acceptable uh absolutely i mean the
the probably the number one question i
get uh as a
you know doing this stuff and talking
about the movie is so i gotta ask
do you
and i pretend i don't know what you're
doing
oh you believe in bigfoot
i don't i don't believe in bigfoot but i
do understand how people
especially prior to a lot of the
technology we have today and and the
idea of
spiritual
mythical
projecting on to this world that they're
in
like and yeah i get it i i can certainly
understand why people would think that
and there's something in
i don't think it's in the movie but uh
uh where pyle is uh talking about in the
book because again he is a uh scientist
a professor a uh um and this goes
against a lot of you know what he
is trained to believe and he writes
about
how
given the woods and given and i believe
this now too after having been in there
given the
world that one could
uh live in and and raise their own
creatures or whatever um
you know uh not really you know not
humans raising the creatures but
creatures raising their own families
yeah over generations you can see how
they
quite easily could
they could exist and they could exist
without being found and discovered and
not very many people are in that
interior as we were in you know yeah
yeah
so that's a yes
i'll put you down for a maybe you can
put me down for a yeti
yeti queen uh there's a great scene that
they did send between you and um
forgetting the actor's name from dead
man uh great act um oh gary farmer yeah
there's farmer yeah he's great
i i
always loved seeing him and he looks
great in the scene so he was so good in
uh dead man but he was i mean just uh
i i was thrilled when i found out he was
going to do that part and he's kind of
intimidating in a way because that's
really that's a lot of his
he's very soft-spoken and
a man of you know like the stuff that he
says is kind of important he's got a lot
of gravity
a lot of gravity yeah yeah he
strikes me that way and this scene is
interesting because he um presents
a position that i've never heard uh said
so kind of clearly um that that's one of
the things that made me when i read the
script uh and the script changed quite a
bit but that idea
of presenting that
viewpoint and not speaking down to it
and uh um and kind of a reversal
of what we are accustomed to seeing
really drew me to this
and i was like all right this is this is
going to
be interesting it's going to be fair
it's going to be not
just so people know it's a scene between
uh so robert uh represents um
a much more pragmatic human element of
uh deforestation you think of
deforestation am i speaking i may not
know the context properly um yeah well
back then it was a it was a very big
issue because uh yeah it was about shops
it was about the logging
in the 90s
and it was quite contentious between the
communities and
uh two-dimensional applications to each
side and people had the bumper stickers
you know uh and that was kind of the
mentality in the uh discourse at the
time
um and so you represent the obviously
the environmentalist side what who would
like uh his character would probably
refer to like you know in a pejorative
way as like like um
you know a
tree hugger
lefty or something and um and you're
talking about the spot at owl which at
the time i remember being a big issue i
i don't i think it had had it recently
gone extinct or or it was close it was
it was in danger of going extinct yeah
and uh and he says
he says well have you ever met a spotted
owl have you ever seen encountered one
you're like no i would you know
and he says it's something you don't
often think about in terms of endangered
or extinct species which is like well
what good are they you know what they're
after
yes
and
yeah i what i i'm curious to
know how you think about that what you
think about that in terms of because
there's there's so many creatures
obviously going extinct we're
experiencing like a sixth extinction and
um so
they're constant species disappear well
i think as as the character as gary
farmer's character and he plays the
foreman the logging foreman and he talks
about the jobs but but again it's not
it's not condescending and it's not
there's an actual discussion and it's
not
and he brings up a lot of valid points
and kind of shuts my character down into
a degree
where there's there's not a lot of
uh the retorts are just like well i mean
there's
you know we should be able to figure
something out you know or something it
just yeah your exchange uh it ends with
and i don't want to
you know i hate at the risk of like
recounting the whole scene but it goes
your argument is that well if we lose
the spot if we lose this species of
insect then we lose the larger creatures
that feed on it the reptiles and then on
and on up to us and then there are fewer
people eventually and he says okay
there's a great kind of balanced
um
and yeah uh i loved that exchange
yeah you have that feeling too like i'm
not being condescended to in a way that
i'm so often condescending condescended
to especially in hollywood yes that take
a liberal uh uh you know
a bias totally when you were growing up
was that was acting ever something that
you wanted to do or was it specifically
you wanted to be comedian
um both i think i think
i i
i think stand-up came later as the sense
of like oh i i'm going to be a stand-up
comic as opposed to being funny or silly
and i was always funny and silly i i
moved around constantly when i was a kid
and so i was often the new kid
and so there would be two
you know almost like in a bipolar sense
in
some classes i'd be shy i would never
say a word in the back and then in other
classes
uh where i guess i intuited that
this was a safe place to do it i was
silly and and boisterous and uh and you
know yeah provocative or whatever and uh
um
so i knew that worked right to a degree
right
and i think i had that
thing
uh
i was just
born with uh and my one of my sisters as
well of just sort of
wanting to perform why i can't tell you
what it is but yeah yeah it'll be fun to
get up on stage and do that stuff do i
um i think it's in shut up you [ __ ]
baby where you talk about
i mean you talk a lot about growing up
in georgia as um
one of the only jewish kids uh if not
the only and um
so i i when i think of your childhood uh
i i think of that story where you go
over your friend's house
and the parent
the mother was like now david david i
gotta ask you
about y'all's people ate uh regular you
know and she
she's trying to figure out how jewish
kids function as opposed to um yeah it
was it was
remarkable the uh
uh
oh i mean mostly well-meaning but the
ignorance was was stunning sometimes
like they really
and again this would be
you know 70s
um
when when i was like younger i mean as i
got older it wasn't that wasn't brought
up so much but um
but
the peop you know people this kind of
southern baptist
uh rural suburban
uh
mentality back when there were only you
know what uh
11 channels of tv or whatever yeah
and no internet and
and just what they thought
what they thought jews jews were and did
and it was really
it was limited to pretty much fiddler on
the roof it was like fiddler on the roof
and then and then the kind of
archetypical
uh
new york jew you know yeah it was really
like that's their idea of what jews are
and then and then you know the
occasional
uh nazi propaganda poster
i know y'all's people burst out into
song and take diane keaton
so so they're you know they're that
thing about um
you know yeah can y'all's people eat
oatmeal yeah it's a legitimate you know
like people like i don't want to
be rude but it's right
yeah that's the well-meaning part it's
that's that's why that bit is so funny
because it you presented in such a kind
of sweet southern
yeah that well-meaning way like i i
don't want to offend you
yeah uh it's so good and i also think
about your experience um
in because i'm actually about to go to
atlanta in a couple days i'm working
there for for a week and uh whenever i
got from there oh did you oh yeah
i was working i we i was in a production
that's why the the beard shaved to go
back to what you were bringing up before
um
yeah we i was in the middle of working
well not even in the middle we were
almost done uh
on
a show that
gosh i think i got
i mean it was like
thanksgiving from right after
thanksgiving i was in atlanta until uh
off and on um
and then we got shut down on march
12th i want to say oh my god and sent
home and
we were in the middle of episode six of
an eight episode oh my god
and
and i'm not even in episode eight i was
i'm just in yeah so i was like oh my god
so close so the pandemic ended up being
really tragic
yeah it affected me in a very negative
way justin and i'll never forgive it
i'm first in line for any handouts
[Laughter]
um oh man so you have to go back and
finish it up uh well i'm so curious i
won't ask you because no one will care
or be able to relate really but i'm
curious about the um
all the protocols and how they're doing
stuff uh oh it was well i was uh as i
might imagine um
anybody would be uh i was nervous about
every aspect of it i was i was nervous
about leaving new york which is
relatively safe and behaves itself and
we're able to enjoy certain amenities
because we all acted like adults
um
and going to a state going to georgia
where they don't have that and people
you know that's that's yeah
um
you know and at the time it was
particularly bad um
and up front there i know and my
family's still there and i'm you know
they are i was wondering they're still
in roswell
yeah uh no they're not in roswell my mom
is uh i got her a condo in midtown and
and my sister and sister-in-law live in
north ruth hill so just
put me
part of the city but not you know not
smacking downtown or whatever but um
uh
god i feel like i know your sister but i
think it's only because of
your documentaries and that she's been a
part of you
i've seen her
i got two sisters one is one is in north
carolina and that's the one that i
do
stories about the one a little bit more
okay what's the word what's the word
redneck no
white truck not white rat what what's
the trying to think of the
um
no i have two sisters so uh um
yeah one's in north carolina and uh
and
do you fight about you must constantly
be at each other's throats about pi you
you seem like you're such different
with my little sister dude in north
carolina no she doesn't know
uh first of all she's she's anti-trump
uh
yeah she's she's definitely um
uh
not that she's active in any way shape
or form uh but she's
uh
i mean she has
uh you know um
gay friends and there's uh um she's
she's
progressive not in a not in a proactive
way but she's definitely uh
liberal leaning for sure
and that's how we were all brought up
and yeah
but uh her community certainly isn't i
mean she's in the she's in the woods
she's in the boonies in north carolina
and uh wow in the blue ridge not like
near like asheville kind of area
no she's a uh east of that okay
but uh um
in atlanta tiny town sorry dude were you
at least able to see your family down
there and and are they behaving yeah oh
well they're i mean my mom's 82 i want
to say something like that 81 82 and and
so uh um
you know she was in the hospital two
years ago with a very
big scare and she was in icu for quite a
while
um twice he was in for ten days came out
and then four days later they go back in
and it was really a scary time and yeah
um
and
and so she's like i'm not
you know i don't ever want to go through
that again and she's been she was she
was in her
uh apartment condo um
i think she was i want to say 70
something days straight without holy
[ __ ] and my sister would get her food
out of the grocery store and they'd be
masked up with gloves and leave it at
her front door yeah and now
now it's it's uh like she's able to go
to my sisters and we've all hung out my
i
because my wife who's also in the
business is in yeah of course she's in
toronto
so
she and she's there they have to do two
weeks of hardcore quarantine you cannot
leave wow i mean they track you you are
inside for 14 days you don't leave and
now she's she's starting to shoot she
started shooting yesterday wow was she
climbing the walls two weeks i mean
she did okay i mean it's
i think at this point we know so many
people have done it and we
yeah uh
i mean i had to walk my dog so i had to
go out at least three times a day but
when we were in the thick of it here in
the city
where it was
you know nobody's out everything's
locked up uh
that you're hearing sirens i live off of
a main you know uh uh
main
road that is uh uh goes east to west and
um
uh so we're you would hear sirens like
pretty every few minutes just
i'm talking about like the in the really
bad like
10 days
to two weeks two and a half weeks part
where
before we started getting a handle in
new york city when they were like body
bags and refrigerator trucks
burying bodies in [ __ ] central park i
mean it was crazy oh my god oh my god
it was nuts dude it was this april may
this uh yeah it was uh
uh end of march
april i think we were kind of out of it
by may but um
so when they sent you home from this
thing march 12th around there were you
thinking like oh they're this is over
they're overreacting had you been
keeping yes i did i did think that i did
my initial thing was because the
the director of that episode um
so the way it happened was i got a call
i was supposed to be you know in at
whatever
8 am pickup or something like that and
um
got a call that the director had a fever
so they were going to shut down for
happy day
um and i thought that was ridic like the
director had a fever
come on guys
it started you know we had been hearing
about it since like january february but
it hadn't really it was only bad in
i think washington state and new york
and new jersey at that point that was it
right
and like and then
that turned into the whole day was shut
down then uh i think it was the next day
they said we're shutting down for three
weeks so you go home and i'm there with
my daughter i have a three and a half
year old right um
uh
and again my my wife was is was working
she was gonna she was in toronto at the
time no no no she was doing something
else but she was gonna come down um but
that all got cancelled and
um
and then
three weeks
when i got back here
that's when i got a real clear
understanding of like oh
we're not going back up in three weeks
guys we're not yeah we're lucky if it's
gonna be three years i mean this is
crazy
and
then new york got a handle on everything
yeah uh
and i'm you know
proud of of my
you know fellow people here uh citizens
or for treating it seriously and
behaving themselves and now we have like
open street restaurants we have all
these great oh my god it's
yeah i know
it kind of is it's there's something so
european about it i had never seen new
york like that um yeah and it's going to
be permanent they're going to make that
pregnant thing too yeah they said so i
think velocity sets up
about a month ago
yeah um
i hate you know it's hard to talk about
anything in a positive light during this
time without prefacing it with like
you know obviously it's horrible what's
happening but there are some you know
the restaurant situation in new york for
example is like that's kind of cool
i wish it had income at this expense but
i mean that's smart great good
cities will yeah take adversity and
learn from it and uh um
you know hopefully there's i think
there's going to be less um traffic i
think from this video forward uh you
know they're taking spaces right it
would normally be parking spaces
and now you can it's uh seating for
dining and those are going to stay not
everywhere but in these i think there's
i don't want i want to say like 39 of
these
where they just close off the uh the
from one end to another yeah in the west
village i mean all those little cornelia
and
jones a lot of those little streets
there off of 6th avenue i i couldn't
believe it it was like what they do for
you know street fairs or whatever dude i
take my daughter on the weekend uh
we go i'm
around the corner from vanderbilt in
prospect heights and i love it there
they shut off uh pacific all the way up
to
i don't know whatever it is uh you know
saying i can't remember what sterling or
whatever it is they shut the whole thing
is shut down everybody is out in the
streets families
everybody's wearing their masks yeah
paving and wearing their masks and uh
and i take my kid there with their
scooter and there's all the kids and
their scooters and they're all playing
in the street there's no oh my god
everybody's eating it's very as you said
very european and it's the best it's the
most hopeful optimistic thing
in this time of absolute [ __ ] yeah
and terrifying uncertainty you have this
thing like on the weekends
we all come out as a community it's very
new york yeah
yeah
i'm like why do i spend so much money to
live here and it's like oh yeah
well uh yeah it's it's very different
but now of course because i
i know your stuff so well i'm now
thinking about
about the rollerblader after 9 11.
there's something post-9 11 about this
yeah well that guy
you know sometimes people ask me if uh
like i
can't remember one hand the times that
i've exaggerated
right like that is an absolute for real
he had a gas mask
oh you weren't meaning you weren't
exaggerating no i'm not i was oh
i'm telling you i i
that was absolutely
a guy in his [ __ ]
you know disco tight disco shorts
whatever uh
rollerblading
tanks they're tanks on the street yes
they were right that's right
uh people was right
right yeah you're crazy your other post
9 11 observation that i i'll never
forget is um when when you
you realized that the city was going to
make it and things were going to go back
to normal when you saw a a guy in a
in a garbage truck with with remnants of
the buildings in the back driving
alongside a woman and hitting on her oh
yeah that's also true i was at tompkins
square park when i saw that that guy was
going down avenue a yeah and uh
and there's a guy hanging off of a
filthy garbage truck
yeah i'm just hitting on women it's just
like in the most like primitive like
blatant like what's up baby yeah
as if the woman's gonna stop and be like
i'm i you say it better than but as if
that's ever gonna work
[Music]
[Music]
do people when they approach you because
i feel like i
know you i think so much better than i
do we've spent a little time together
but do people approach you with um
it's just such familiarity
you know people who know your comedy do
they um are they very familiar
yeah yeah yeah
that's that's fine i uh
uh
you know sometimes they're a bit too
familiar you know uh as well as anybody
there's a line that can be crossed and
yeah everybody has a different
place where that line is but um
do you draw different boundaries when
you're with your your you said you have
a three and a half year old uh oh
absolutely yeah yeah yeah but i gotta
say one of the one of the upsides uh
um
tiny little upsides for me uh
uh as
for during covet is um i don't
i you know i've got a mask and a hat on
and right that's an i know and people
don't recognize me you know david i i
know again this is not going to be
relatable to people we're going to
probably sound a little douchey but i i
was um
i'm not saying that i'm not saying like
i'm glad this has happened no no no no i
know i know it's
it's a an effect of what just happened
no of course but um that's true but
going down i i hadn't been in the west
village on the weekends um
in so long it's just an area that i
avoided it it had gotten really you know
you've been there it's it's so crowded
on the weekend so touristy and um
it was it was so nice to just walk
around yeah
you know uh by i'm with you right yeah
yeah um
uh
at what point did that start changing
for you i mean in turn you you have done
so many different things you uh you must
get recognized for
of course we should really get to alvin
and the chipmunks before we run out of
time yeah yeah please please
i mean let's let's address the elephant
in the room
that the little tiny precocious elephant
um
was was
that surprised me because at that point
i had known you so well uh
as like um there was something very punk
rock about
you and and i i knew your work so well
as being subversive and um
sure i mean i ate a lot of [ __ ] for that
yeah i know i know and i don't want to
rehash anything that but like but
i
i mean the the
i it's not like i don't understand where
people are coming from but the
the answer is uh and it may not be a
satisfying answer to people but the
answer was
i hadn't worked in six months which is
kind of an eternity uh um and you really
do start thinking am i ever going to
work again totally and
uh
i think if i hadn't worked if it had
been two months i probably would have
said no and look i don't regret uh any
of it um
so i i
happily took the job uh i don't think
anybody
anybody anticipated it would be as
wildly successful as it was and spin off
and i it was contractually obligated to
do i mean that's part of anybody's
contract you sign up and it has a
contingency thing just in case it does
become wildly popular i was contracted
to do uh
three of them should it see i i didn't
know that david i i
and i now i'm wondering if i was this
why i must have been
i must have i'm sure i'm sure you were
uh it's just standard any any of those
type of things yeah yeah but was the
experience a positive one shooting it i
mean
you're very funny the first one was fine
the the and the second one was okay the
third one was uh uh
i'd say
this is a different category of
a bad experience like the like shooting
the dark divide was really hard and yeah
a lot of those scrapes and bruises you
see are all real and it was a tough
thing and it was
there were no amenities there was no
craft service there was no i mean down
and dirty and tough and not fun in that
sense
um
but doing the third alvin and chipmunks
movie was so
uh they were so disrespectful of me and
so mean like just petty and weird and i
could tell you a bunch of different
anecdotes of like
it was it was really strange because
when you think of uh and let me put this
through the
to to preface this by saying i can't
tell you how many parents
over the decades have been like man
thank you for doing that because i have
to watch that [ __ ] thing
40 times and at least you're funny at
least yeah you know i've gotten that
comment a million times it always makes
me feel better that in in conjunction
with
kids who are like hey yeah
yeah kids loved it and it was
international i mean i got recognized in
mozambique on a beach
but god
but uh yeah they were so shitty to me
and i always like
you know the stuff that's funny that's
not in the script that's stuff that i'm
working on and i'm a professional and i
come in and i know my lines and i'm
there right when i'm supposed to be and
i
come up with new things and i pitch
things and yeah and yeah just for people
sorry to interrupt david but i i don't i
don't i'm not sure people know how much
on a script like that on a movie like
that because i've done others
i remember herbie fully loaded being
like that whereas the script was not
there it was written by funny people but
it just wasn't and so they they
encourage you i mean the studio people
encourage you to they love somebody like
you because you're writing for them too
yes yes and uh um and i assume that
happens every time i'm uh hired they're
hiring me in part because of a writer's
eye as well um which i'm happy with i'm
happy to
give suggestions they can take it or
leave them it doesn't matter but yeah i
just can't even help myself i just i'm a
writer first and foremost and you're
coming up with stuff and in performance
and i take scripts home and i come back
the next morning like hey what if i did
this what if we inverted this line what
the you know whatever um so they're
lucky that they have an emmy nominated i
mean you know one of their it was just
again the first two were fine uh yeah
that last one was just so
inexplicably
weird just awful awful uh
and there was a whole backstory to it
that i don't want to bore people with
but they they were shitty in every
single way at every point
and i actually lost 150 000
of what would have been a bonus because
of a a language in the
contract which said if i don't i don't
know the language but if you don't
promote something
or if you were negative or something
like that i went on conan and i
described the producer who was just
awful to me just terrible terrible
just again so mean and unnecessarily so
and petty and weird and
unpleasant and uh
there's one thing that a lot of the
hollywood studio heads have that it's
almost like in politics
where
it's not about the thing you're fighting
for you know studio versus agents or
whatever it's about winning
it's so quickly doesn't it's not about
the thing that you know where like me is
the actor the director or the writer
whatever i'm i'm
you know arguing for this or i'm trying
to get this thing in the contract and
then the
lawyer and you know your team is going
back and forth with their team and it's
not about
the thing itself it's about who's gonna
win a lot of these fights are not at all
creative based they're not about no no
that's what i'm saying that's that's
pretty much one
there's a juvenile it's like you you you
find yourself placating these people in
a way you would a child because they
want to win they want to be able to you
know i i won that and sometimes you have
to make change the language so it
appears that they won and you are
acquiescing a point or something uh
uh because they they
it's it's just weird i felt that uh in
particular with
the issues i was having on the third
album
i think here's one really petty thing
they did that was so
shitty and this is amongst
a number of them but
keep in mind
this is the third movie i'm doing that
i'm contractually obligated to do um
a part of the back story that it go into
was i was in london at the time in
pre-production on the show and we've
been asking for a year am i going to be
in it
am i going to be in the third oh i need
to know because i've got you know a
producer of the show and i've got 50
people todd margaret yeah
50 people whose lives are you know whose
jobs yeah and i'm here in london
and
and you know we would go we would ask
them every
four or five days and for months months
and months months months we don't know
could be we don't know and how do you
not know and then we
right anyway i'm not going to go into
that whole thing but it was awful
we were shooting in hawaii and i get to
the location uh base camp
and there's
um
keep in mind i'm number two on number
two
um
jason in this one yes yes
meaning for those who don't know you
know the hierarchy of your stars yeah
so number two is as as high as you can
get without being number one
sorry if i'm interrupting that you're
gonna get back to this david i'm just
curious did you then have to put a pin
in the todd margaret shoot did you have
to then oh yeah for oh it was it was
brutal and we lost cast and we lost it
they were god
oh yeah oh that's important
yeah and i can i can tell you in another
we're talking i'll give you that okay
horrors of how that works but
and you know how you you lose locations
you lose oh yeah uh crew you lose all
kinds of [ __ ] and i know you were so
involved in that it was a low budget
lower budget thing so yeah wow but so
that [ __ ] that sucks that happened but
you're you so you're in hawaii sorry so
i'm in hawaii and i go to
base camp uh
and there's
um you know a bunch of really nice
trailers and then there's like this
uh broken down smaller like uh you know
those kind of curved roundy ones yeah
yeah i actually want to get one like a
camper van type thing you would detach
it and there's and it's like i'm talking
it's got to be 40 years old
you know rust and it's discolored
and they're like that's your trailer
and i know immediately i know
immediately what's going on yeah and
this is in the beginning of like are you
and they're like yeah sorry man that's
all that's that's all they had
and i call my age you know we've been
going back and forth for weeks now at
this point because like they they called
me i was actually at
a store with my wife and i get a call
this is right before uh christmas i get
a call
um
uh david i have uh i have brian and tim
and harris on the phone and you know
it's you know when it's your agent
lawyer man all of them it's only going
to be
either really great news or really awful
news it's only going to be that it's
never going to be anything in between
yeah yeah and i'm like uh
okay
and i'm luckily i'm kind of by the doors
of the the store we've just gone in and
and i and i mouth to my wife who was my
wife at the time and i'm like uh hang on
a second this is it's uh and and the
first thing you say is are you sitting
down
like what is it
so they they are doing uh the third
album the chipmunks
you are you are in it you're you're all
over it
and they want you in hawaii
uh in two weeks or in 10 days
and i'm in london
like i can't even and so a million
things
are like what i can't even
maybe wait wait wait wait maybe it
wasn't maybe they wanted me there on
like
because i remember saying i can't even
get there physically i would have to go
to new york
get close
it must have been like a week or
something or friday or one of those
things
that's got to be a [ __ ] you right i mean
like yeah i'm just imagining well how do
they not
i said i can't possibly do that
um and you know we've been asking
forever i'm in the middle of
pre-production blah blah and and they
said yes we told them all this and they
said
if he doesn't show up we'll sue him for
breach of contract
that's how they started that's how this
whole thing started that's the
communication
that's aggressive right away like
hostile right away
yeah hostile and not i mean as a
producer you produce stuff you try to
make everybody happy you're balancing a
ton of [ __ ]
especially the lead actor a lead actor
who's done
you know really great work in your
previous
two movies that's crazy
hey i i'm sorry that this went off on
this no no no no i i by the way you know
we can cut anything out and i'm but also
justin i'm gonna have to run uh oh oh
yeah god uh
uh [ __ ] dave do you have do you have
seven minutes uh
yeah sick okay i'm so sorry really quick
questions just uh like a lightning round
kind of thing okay sorry sorry your most
commonly used emoji if you use emojis
would you say
i don't really use them that much but i
annoy
my wife who hates him and then my wife
texts way too much just
stuff that
i don't need to know
because every time he texts i got to
stop pull it out of my pocket
you know hit my security thing look on
yeah and then it's just like okay
i'm like
don't text k anymore please okay i got
it um
so i just i just randomly throw emojis
in so i don't have a comment okay
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
oh baseball oh yeah your
yankees uh
braves and braves and red socks right oh
wow okay uh oh emerson right spend a lot
of time uh if you could have one snack
food for the rest of your life what
would it be
your go-to god i
i i i we're talking about like uh snacks
don't like you're stoned
you just wanna
you crave this thing when you're stoned
but not uh is it any food or is it snack
food like food snack food okay um tell
me if this
works and if it doesn't i'll give you
something else but
um
uh
pretzel rods dipped in peanut butter
oh god yeah
yeah like that you like the trader joe's
things with the peanut butter in the
middle the little bites uh that's that's
a poor man's version yeah i'm talking
about taking the sturdy spiders
yeah
yeah even adding a little salt to the
peanut getting the crunchy
good the good stuff the good yeah
crunchy stuff
crunchy peanut butter mix it around and
then uh i'll have a glass of red wine
and then i'll just dip data the pretzel
rods and the peanut butter it's great
great uh but speaking of that one of my
favorite things uh to watch you on is
doug getting getting dug with hi
uh
during which you say i can't believe
anyone's watching this and i it made me
laugh so hard because i looked at the
youtube views and it's like i think
almost 900 000 people have seen it
um
what's your favorite uh not favorite
movie of all time but the one that you
are really looking forward to showing um
your daughter
uh
charlie and the chocolate factory
yeah uh i think she'll she'll really dig
and i still love it on
multiple levels and um
yeah uh yeah that i i can't wait to show
her that yeah uh what a great three and
a half what a fun
age i can hear her running up like in
here oh god okay uh okay uh if you had
to live somewhere else where would it be
two minutes uh london oh right yeah it's
been a long time right my wife and i
talked about it and we have a lot of
friends there and i i miss it uh i bet
you spent so much time there yeah and
then i i came to really love and
appreciate so many things about it yeah
um
if you could have dinner with three
people that are alive whom you've never
met you just love to sit down and have a
meal with them
gnome chomsky
and um
that i've never met uh uh
or someone you haven't spent significant
time with that you'd like to and maybe
ricky gervais
and
uh
and josh
marshall okay this is great dinner i
would love to be there um
no women allowed who
who are you ever afraid of saying
something like that obviously joking and
now getting in trouble i mean you used
to you'd say the craziest [ __ ]
uh
are you are you more concerned now
getting in trouble how how would i get
in trouble
am i gonna get grounded getting grounded
yeah getting grounded on twitter
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] twitter
yeah
um
if you
who's your favorite muppet david
um
i think when i was a kid it was grover
uh but as i got older it was fozzie bear
yeah yeah
i love fawzi uh if you could be one age
for the rest of your life physically
what would you pick knowing what you
know now being as developed as you are
gosh i'd say
34-35
uh-huh yeah i missed that uh would you
rather be called unattractive or unfunny
oh i
what do you think i said no i've just
i've been called unattractive so many
times that doesn't that will never
bother me
uh i was balding when i was 19. i oh my
god yeah i was uh yeah no um oh oh yeah
no i'd rather i'd rather be
oh you you're unattractive
you're always attractive
you're my first guest who's scoffed at
that like oh please yeah no i i you
people can call me unattractive it's
fine
uh almost done which golden girl do you
most identify with dorothy blanc i have
never seen a golden girls episode no
kidding never seen no kidding uh
uh dogs or cats do you prefer dogs
yes i have a dog
uh do you prefer the beatles or the
rolling stones
man that's tough uh yeah
i don't know
the who
okay okay do you have a favorite beatles
song
i always liked when i was younger i like
glass onion because it references a
bunch of their stuff and i just like the
idea of doing that i thought that was
pretty cool when my daughter was uh
you know just born an infant
i would sing golden slumbers to her and
good night so those two you know
now it's time to say
good yeah so i just sing those two are
so maybe those right now
oh that's beautiful um david i'm so glad
i got to do this because i i know you
have to go and which is good because i
don't have time to um properly
articulate what a huge fan i am of your
work thank you so much justin this is a
pleasure and we had an in-depth
conversation about alvin and the
chipmunks three which i don't think has
ever been a lot of people can say yeah
um
america was waiting
there you go uh
we can all go to bed now damn thanks
dave and the movie looks really you look
incredible in it and uh
and and tell tell amber i say hi uh i
will she'll be back in about a week and
a half i think
oh cool all right well i look forward to
seeing you again in in person um and
thank i really appreciate you all right
i'm right over the bridge
i i would love to i would love to see
you i would love it all right man we're
a new european city yeah we're uh come
up to vanderbilt it's awesome
so well that just happened happened
i don't know what i was going for i just
said say i i was trying uh david cross i
he he has a very unique voice a very
unique cadence to his
delivery i've heard him a lot more than
i've seen him i would say because i've
do you remember you had a was it just
your playlist it's my play was my play
well it was on it was first the cd that
i had in the comments that's what it was
yeah it was on a cd it was on a mixity
that you shut up you [ __ ] baby yeah
it was a sound but it was it was mixed
in
like certain tracks of his comedy
special yeah were mixed in with song
great songs
so i've been on so many road trips where
it'd be like great song great song great
song great three-minute bit from david
cross great song great song and um
you'd think that if you're in the mode
of like listening to great music yeah
you would skip over uh like a random
three minute but it was always
it was i always listened to him so i
knew that material so well because i
know
so incredibly funny that i
know his voice i got i i know his voice
so well so to hear him talk
just to hear him well i made it converse
it made me starstruck just to hear his
voice i'm telling you that's how i am
around him i have to be very careful
because i also feel like he's the type
of person that uh has a very high
he's very sensitive to like [ __ ] you
know and to phoniness and i've always
been very self-conscious about being too
gushy or over laughing at a stuffer like
even though
yeah i get starstruck around him because
he's so familiar to me that's what i
tried to say to him at one point do
people get really approachable i think
you were appropriately respectful i
could tell you were
um careful with the words you chose
um but you were definitely you paid him
a lot of respect okay and he didn't
um
i mean he received it well but he didn't
overly
perceive it you know he wasn't like oh
thank you so much he would kind of like
it sounded like he just kind of took
compliments yeah and he
he must know that based on my behavior
around him and and other people's
behavior but as much as as much as you
did show him respect you didn't
mention mr show or arrested development
but you did mention
alvin and the chipmunks part three
i didn't mention mr show no
weird i mean you know there's certain
things about mr show i think part of
what it was i've heard him talk so much
about mr show and i had just heard
uh his entire mark maran interview where
he goes
and i was very self-conscious about
retreading a lot of that stuff and like
even though i'm sure it would have been
interesting that's right you shouldn't
yeah
over research yeah shouldn't listen to
other interviews that people have done
before you interviewed me right yeah it
would have been but you know then what
do you what do you want him to say about
it exactly yeah it's a brilliant sketch
show that i created and i know how and
the truthfully the story of how he got
together with bob odenkirk is
i mean it's interesting but it's nothing
that you can't hear i mean like it's out
there it's like new it's been he's
talked about it and it's basically like
you know they met through
uh i think it's janine graffle he was a
what a comedian that right they knew and
they didn't like each other at first and
whatever it wasn't it's not like you
know it's also not a great story it's
not a great story but on marc maron it's
like he goes through the entire timeline
and it's two two hours and 40 minutes
you know uh so i in a weird way i
remember joking about it i'd rather hear
about his dissatisfaction with an
experience like after the chip oh i love
that yeah that was great he he really
lights up about certain things you know
i could tell not that he was
disinterested in other things but yeah
you could tell when he's excited about
things exactly like talking about new
york city he was very excited to talk
about that and he's very excited to talk
about alvin and the chipmunks he's he's
incredibly descriptive i i of the many
things i admire about him his
his ability to um to tell a story to
paint a picture yes is so he's so quick
i he did something in another interview
where he says um he was describing uh a
really funny story about how he used to
he was
just to make money he um was like a
subject in a in a test group for a drug
for like an antacid and he tells a very
funny story about being hungover at one
of these
uh you know the
testing things where they have to take
the they have to first eat a lot of like
awful food like really high in fats food
and drink a lot of boxed wine and stuff
and then take this antacid and um and he
tells us and as he's telling the story
he said i think you know i have to sit
in this room
and it's just with these people these he
calls them like
losers from
you know and uh and he describes them as
it's like being in a bus station in
raleigh durham at three in the morning
and he just says it's so quick yes it's
it's scripted it's specific specific but
i think the best comedians are specific
like my favorite comedians are
incredibly specific and even like i
noticed that the way he talked about um
his snack food how he likes yeah he was
so specific about the press a certain
kind of pretzel rod dipped in with a red
wine like he he really um really paints
a picture really paints a picture he
shaped the way i thought about a lot of
things and the way i i saw the world and
and what i thought was stand-up comedy
uh was and and what was possible with
stand-up comedy and what he did that was
different than any comedian i i had been
familiar with was that he would just
tell stories i realized that stand up
can just be
a person a a great storyteller i admired
your perseverance when he wanted to go
too he
he was like my daughter my
three-year-old daughter is like waiting
for me and you're like okay oh yeah hold
on hold on hold on he got panicky but
you did but i admired i i thought you
were gonna fold i thought you'd be like
okay uh i'll let you get to it but you
really pushed through well he was being
very you know maybe that's a
disrespectful thing here i'm going on
about how much i respect him and i was
like well but he had to get to his
daughter and i was like just what who's
your favorite you know which golden girl
do you identify with but he i he he was
very he seemed so amenable up until that
point and was like seemed really
game and
friendly so i maybe took advantage so we
can't not have someone do the lightning
round i know i know that happened i
don't care how old your daughter is
you know she'll be fine another we gotta
get to dogs or cats um i said wait wait
sorry to interrupt but you know once i
know that they know especially somebody
i admire so much that they have to go
then this whole this is now borrowed
time now it's like
i gotta make it count this better be
important oh you're on like time and a
half speed exactly but also it's like i
start getting really self-conscious
about all those questions when it's like
who's your favorite muppet it's like oh
man or if you're like what three people
do you want to dinner with that are
alive and if there's any hesitation
you're like or or if you've met them or
if you've spent a lot of time with them
or if you know them really well or a
snack just a snack i know
you know or any sport just name a sport
you're not or a made-up person you make
up a person and did he make up that
person by the way oh we might we might
be idiots for not knowing who this you
know what i i didn't want to hey i
didn't want to look stupid his name was
josh marshall i don't know who that is i
don't either and but i was like i didn't
want to address it then i'm sure he's a
real person because it's a very common
sounding name but it'd be fun it would
be a david cross thing to do to just
make up that name because he's so drunk
and it would be a you thing to do to uh
to not call him out on it to be like
yeah oh yes i would like to do tony yeah
well a little bit but he you for the
sake of why we talked about that for the
sake of getting back to his daughter
yeah yeah so i
i'm not gonna be like tell me
not only is he now being kept from his
daughter longer but he's kind of like
exactly struck this
imbecile
yeah somebody probably he might be some
pulitzer prize winner sure he is i i was
shocked never seen the golden girls but
i think it's
pretty fair to say that he's a sophia
right oh yeah oh my god yeah like uh
misanthropic and but with this with a
but i will say this about david that he
has much more uh heart and he's much
more sensitive at heart yeah yeah she
was just yeah she observed everything
and she had kind of a wry take you're
right
you're right
i i just wanted to
clarify it because um i i do think a lot
of people have that misconception uh
that that he's this kind of cynical mis
and i used the word misanthropic and i
just wanted to i think that's why he's
he's gonna be so good in this movie and
that's why it's not a surprise to me
because he is um
he strikes me as a very sensitive it
looks a bit like oscar bait yeah doesn't
it it might hook a few uh uh-huh a few
voters
yeah it might you might not know what i
hate sundance darling written all over
it i know a term i hate which vince
always uses is really funny a nod
he might get a nod
that's awful
yeah let's read a letter i hope it does
i i really like him and i am really
grateful that he did so selfishly i hope
he gets one this is a letter from
sabrina your day
maybe jord like is that's how lord the
singer
oh
r d e e o r d e yeah
and we'll never be royals
subject greetings from venezuela cool
and spooky would you rather oh great
hey long brothers max pearl maggie and
turtles
whoa the whole gang max and pearl got
billing over
maggie yes
max and pearl are our parents dogs for
those confused yeah that's right i
should have clarified just assumed
everyone knows
i forgot people were listening to this
my name is sabrina
i'm 22 years old and live in venezuela i
currently study public relations and i'm
about to graduate next year
congratulations your podcast and anna
ferrisses are the only ones i listen to
basically wow i love your sense of humor
and can't help relating to your dynamic
and inside jokes they remind me a lot of
me and my best friends i hope you're all
taking care of yourselves and as a
fellow beatlemaniac lol i send you all
my lovin oh my lovin
she didn't say that part i added that
could you tell uh heart emoji p.s justin
my boyfriend looks a lot like you wow a
lucky fella
and
like you and anthony keatis
and he
he's sick and tired of my [ __ ] whoa whoa
what does that mean he's sick and tired
she's probably saying that all the time
to him
that's what her [ __ ] probably or her or
maybe that's just
sick and tired of my [ __ ]
and it has nothing to do with what he
looks like maybe maybe not i think it's
i would suspect it's she's sick and
tight which means he's not flattering
i'm appearing that he looks like you
yeah he's not flattered by it yeah
because you don't get it it was it was
flattering if somebody kept saying i
look like brad pitt i'd be like i
wouldn't be sick of it ever you might be
you don't know uh laughing face emoji
crying laughing biggest biggest
compliment though ah pics below not
according to him no no and she she sent
pics but i took it i took a pic oh you
did it okay all right but i want to see
what he looks like let's see
oh
yeah
yeah he does
you know
we have a little bit like a little adam
driver yeah yeah and there's somebody
that i i'm i'm not placing but
oh i know he looks a little like max
mingela doesn't he yeah a little bit
but he has a we have similar wispy
mustaches which he's not gonna like the
sound of that's not a compliment no you
have you do have similar mustaches
because you both have that space in the
middle where hair doesn't crop see
yeah he has a little bit of a peterberg
overbite too like doesn't he
like nice lips he does he does have nice
lips yeah he has great lips i hope he's
not listening to this i hope he is
that's a compliment why wouldn't you
take that compliment from uh especially
from two middle-aged men he doesn't know
complimenting his nice pouty lips we
know lips
i mean we're into the lips i think he
might be creeped out if you heard this
why i'm not saying like i want to like
make out with his lips i i even that
shouldn't that shouldn't bother me but
talking about how nice his lips are is
is a little
objectified well definitely objective
also a little unsettling maybe but she
sent the picture in order that i know
it's her fault it's only gonna make him
give her more [ __ ] yeah and i'd be tired
of her [ __ ] oh right yeah he'll he'll
grow even more tired of that [ __ ] um
attractive guy though i'm i'm flattered
by the comparison you should be
okay here we go would you rathers
number one end up having wallace's fate
in tusk
uh or derry's fate in jeepers creepers
the rest of wallace is your character
yeah thanks yeah in tusk um tusca is a
movie for the the majority of you who
haven't seen it about a uh like a
vincent price
maniacal man who
turns my character into a walrus
basically it's like a body mutilation
movie and then um
jeepers creepers i
i mean
i would rather have me i mean i this is
tough because it's kind of like what we
were talking about the other day so
would you rather become the walrus or
yeah you die at the end of spoiler alert
that's the thing it's like would you
want to live
but but just to
so people can think about it in tusk i
lose my my tongue is taken out my my
arms are i'm put into this i'm sewn into
the
spoiler spoiler alert i'm sewn into the
body of this wall so where so you become
a walrus basically but where do you you
you live in a zoo or something right
yeah and my girlfriend played by genesis
rodriguez uh ends up getting together
with i think haley joel osman's
character my best friend and so i have
to see them they come to visit me and
they throw so you're in a zoo i'm trying
to
imagine what the
life would be yeah it's yeah in a little
pen
uh i have a little like are you fed good
food mackerel and stuff probably raw
fish and stuff yeah why would i do
cheaper scrapers you'd want you'd rather
i wouldn't want to live like yeah that'd
be really hard i don't think i could get
used to that like no after living as a
human for someone what is there another
one have sex with the creeper or
or
or have sex with howard howe jeez who's
that he's the character that um the late
great michael
uh oh oh oh oh
um michael parks michael parks sorry
michael price wait would you rather have
sex show runners for family michael
parks or uh the creeper
yeah oh and they said howard how dressed
is a walrus of course these are very
specific to uh as many times as they
please
this is so weird
the creeper i guess really i don't know
it's it's
the creeper only because it's
not uh
not an old man
and it would be such a different kind of
monster i know but it's a different kind
of experience so i wouldn't even
associate it with having sex with a
human right i know yeah i wouldn't want
to do either yeah
okay third turn someone else into mr
tusk or gouge and eat someone else's
eyes good lord sabrina good jord
tur good you're these are crazy turn
someone else into mr tusk or gouge any
again mr tusk is the walrus character
okay um so basically do the thing yeah
yeah uh i would not want to do that to
anyone mr t i would goujan these are i
these are really hard um you know i
would go
how did you need someone's i would say
that one
only it's faster it's faster it's less
um i hate to say this it's
less uh abusive yeah well i think in
part because it's faster and i think
there's something more abusive just in
the length of time it takes to turn
someone into a wall oh also i found a
way around the real the most tragic
element of it if you were able to pick
the person and you could pick somebody
you already can't see
so their eyes are of no real use to them
already
it'd still be awfully galaxy yeah i
don't think if i had to guess sabrina
would say no no it's got to be a person
if i knew sabrina yeah um okay well
those are truly awful uh thank you
sabrina
um but you know halloween themed i know
it's past halloween now but it's still
you know the time the ghouls are still
in the air oh we can still do that voice
it's the holiday season
yes until the next vernal equinox um
okay well thank you sabrina uh and
thanks to sabrina's lover for putting up
with uh her
what she thinks are flattering his
expression in this picture he looks like
don't you he knew
that she was taking a picture of him in
order to submit it to this podcast yup
yup he looks over it he looks like he's
tired of uh hearing that so thank you to
sabrina and if you guys would like to
write in our email address is life is
short at wandery.com
and
thank you so much to the just the great
uh one my favorite i'm going to say it
my favorite wow i think he is bill i
mean bill burr is up there he's one of
okay i'll say one of my favorites but if
you say that now
if you have another great comedian like
if jerry seinfeld comes on the show yeah
right i won't let you say he's my
favorite okay so he's one of my
favorites okay um the legendary i can
say that yes he's a legendary uh
comedian and and a great actor so go see
his movie the dark divide uh it's it's i
think it's wide i think you can see it
it's streaming somewhere and just the
stories of him
the harrowing experience of shooting it
aren't you curious just based on that
yes very curious um so thank you to
david and everyone listening and we'll
talk to you next week and stay tuned for
a voice memo
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
it's uh co-hosted and produced by you
christian long and also produced by
megan monaco and your producer is
michelle mieshlands two executive
producers audio and audio sergio
enriquez executive producers are
speaking of executive producers we got
marshall louie and hernan lopez for uh
company and the name of which escapes me
i believe you know wondering
[Music]
hey everyone this is alvin i hope you
enjoyed listening to the podcast
christian
i have fun
and margaret what about you did you like
the show
you don't have to force your voice up to
make it go higher because the app does
that oh that's my real voice though
sorry didn't mean to slam you
see you next week everyone
you